this series is brought to you by Globe
planets welcome back team we are diving
into part three today with objects now
twin motion has a variety of different
objects so we're going to get right into
it again if you're joining us for the
first time and you're just seeing this
amazing model and thinking how do I get
my hands on it there's a link down below
completely free so you can grab it and
join along so let's talk about the
objects available to us directly in Twin
motion and then we'll move on to the
objects we can find on the internet as
well so first of all on to the left hand
side of the palette you're going to have
your objects if you dive into objects
simply by clicking once you're going to
get a variety of different elements
we'll go through these one by one
because again this is a very thorough
course to make sure that you're at
Absolute Pro so diving into home we're
going to have a variety of amazing
things to be able to Showcase this
better let's fly inside our house let's
turn on our little pedestrian mode so by
clicking the I tapping our man going
pedestrian mode we are now at human
scale and we can't accidentally go
outside of our actual environment
now let's click on living room and see
what options we have a billion one
options again so so many options but
let's start with electronic appliances
nice TV directly above our fireplace
here in the center so let's click it
once click it onto where we want to did
it and then press escape to get rid of
it if the TV is too small we can select
our TV once hit the tab button slowly to
adjust through the different options
press tab again we get our three squares
with the fourth being in the center
which allows us to scale like we did
before if we want to drag that out to
1.3 drag that out make that TV bigger we
simply can or command Z command Z undoes
that we can simply hold and hover over
the center so it highlights all of the
cursors and go tap 1.5 enter and we have
a huge huge TV now we can also use any
of the intermediate spaces in between
these arrows to move them along that
axis as well so now we have this
stunning TV with a strange reflection of
the sky but we'll get to that a little
bit later of how we can get rid of that
horrendous Sky reflection because you
wouldn't have a scar reflecting off and
say they're there at all if we scroll
through our abundance of objects you'll
see a ton keep coming up and in Twin
motion they've recently added even more
fantastic items that you can simply
download directly into twin motion so if
you didn't like that TV that was in the
wall where you could pick another one of
these TVs or potentially maybe you
wanted to download a tablet so let's
select that little download Arrow let
the tablet download for a few seconds
click on the tablet once
hover over where we want it to be
created click once again
and it will create that tablet on the
side so now I can press Escape Zoom to
my tablet click on it adjust it to where
I want it to be so let's say one of the
kids is accidentally left it just on the
side it can get bumped it could get
knocked but they've left it there and
we're showcasing it in our render if we
come back across we're going to see a
variety of additional objects available
to us as well so if we wanted to go into
sofas we could introduce a sofa couch
directly in front of us however
personally I hate every single one of
these objects in Twin motion as a sofa
they're also generic they're also boring
and they're incredibly incredibly cheap
so we could continue to go through each
and every single one of these look at
all the kids toys you know have some fun
find some entertainment systems put a
pork table in if we wanted to there is
actually a designated space over here
for a pool table so we would definitely
be putting one of these in what kind of
pool table should we put in I personally
don't love any of them but this one is
the best because it's got a black top so
let's download this pool table wait a
few seconds for it to download click
once click again to create the object
and position it exactly where we want it
to go that looks like it's definitely
not in the center of the room the center
is roughly where this window is and
aligned with the fire pit so that's
roughly where the center and the pool
table would go if we were to have one
and you'd be able to see people playing
a lovely game pool behind now we've
gotten sidetracked from the main points
here we want to come all the way back to
our main library we want to talk about
the second available option in Twin
motion if you come down to sketchfab and
select sketchfab once again you're going
to have an abundance of categories to
work your way through and it will drive
you nuts but if we want to Simply go on
furniture at home select it once you'll
see I've downloaded a ton of different
objects in the past and they're
automatically saved to my twin motion so
because I've used all of these in the
past they're immediately there I don't
have to download them again I don't have
to search for them they just come up as
first which is really really good and
really helpful now let's say I was
looking for a sofa I was looking for a
couch you could also just simply type in
sofa upper top let it do its thing see
what it can find and it will show you a
million and one different examples with
sofas basically anything that anybody
has ever created on sketchfab is
available to download for free which is
phenomenal it means you can find sofas
from Ikea you can find sofas from your
favorite designer you can basically find
anything under the sun that's available
if you search hard enough and that's the
big if because it takes a long time to
go through all of these options so if we
undo that and let's drag and drop one of
these sofas that I've used in the past
let's grab this sofa here drop it in the
middle in front of that TV and then I'm
simply just gonna duplicate it across so
by pressing tab I can then hover over
the Green Arrow because I want to shift
it to the left hold shift while clicking
and dragging letting go and it will
produce a copy a dialog box
if you create an instance copy that
means anything that you do to the right
hand so far or the original so far is
immediately going to translate to the
copy that you've made this works vice
versa for both and basically everything
that uses copy function for if you
select copy they will work independently
of each other which makes life super
easy but also challenging so make sure
you're selecting the right instance or
copy every single time and paying
attention this sofa needs to be the same
so let's go instance let's press OK
let's rotate it 180 degrees
and then let's simply adjust this sofa
back into the other one move it across a
little bit so we have this unique
double-sided sofa by holding command and
clicking on the second couch I can
select them both at the same time and
move them wherever I want to
go back to my main sketch Fab and type
in coffee table
you can type in multiple words and it
will search them as individual words so
you may have some weird strange things
pop up like this car but otherwise you
should generally get most of what you're
looking for I have no idea what this
house would look like inside I haven't
really thought about it too much so
let's simply just download any of these
tables here maybe this glass table here
would be quite lovely had this happened
during this tutorial because it's a
prime example of a few of the glitches
inside twin motion I've pressed the
download button but nothing is happening
it's only 524 kilobytes so it should
have downloaded in a heartbeat but it's
basically glitched I can't download it I
can't pause it I really can't do
anything unfortunately at the moment I
don't have a workaround for anybody
which means you have to Simply go find
another coffee table that you like
download it and use that one so let's
try it download this one as an
alternative
and you say it started downloading as
well as provide the pause option whereas
if I scroll back up that one hasn't
moved at all now this takes me to my
third and final library inside twin
motion obviously you have your cars and
you use the library and characters
so if you go into characters you can
drag and drop any of the people into
your scenes if you go into Vehicles you
can drag and drop any of the cars into
your scenes similar in sketchfab you
have vehicles and you have characters
and creatures so you can drag and drop
very specific high-end cars into the
project as well you just simply search
them and go ahead and download them
however you also have the mega scans
library now the mega scans 3D assets are
actually scanned objects from The Real
World as an example let's go into
interior let's go into furniture and
let's go table you'll see a number of
different tables have come up and
available to us in theory Mega scans is
all about realistic high quality objects
from The Real World scanned in to the
digital world they're basically creating
digital twins of everything available
therefore objects will be of
significantly greater quality and detail
well but they're not going to have too
many options and a lot of them are going
to be just so strange that you're not
going to want to use them as an example
let's drop this wooden table in go back
to our drone mode so we can inspect it
quite closely and you'll see that it is
an extremely well detailed table it
isn't really like it's been modeled
because there's so many strange little
curves undulations changes in the
material and that's because it has been
3D scanned which is incredible that is
such a cool thing that you can do
nowadays you can take your iPhone you
can scan any material and you can
actually develop it yourself into twin
motion if you're using the right apps
but let's delete that table go back to
some of our other options maybe we want
a fireplace maybe there's something
amazing that we can put in if you're in
an old Heritage building these would be
incredible but for the purpose of this
not so much you can also find things
like details in extremely intricate wall
panels wall detailing very three
historic and exquisitely crafted items
then unfortunately we no longer do but
this is where you can find them inside
the mega scans library now if you've
ever asked yourself what is the
difference between a high quality render
an average render you see all over
Instagram well the difference is the
quality the care and the assets
that's why I've teamed up with globe
plans to be able to give you an
incredible library of the world's best
3D photorealistic vegetation trees
shrubs and everything in between are
these Globe plants for a very long time
now you've seen them in my videos before
and finally we've come together to be
able to actually bring you a series
worthwhile so if you're looking for some
incredible 3D plants regardless of where
you are situated around the world it
doesn't matter if you're in America
Australia Africa Europe they've got all
of the plants available for every single
person around the globe so make sure you
check out Globe plants in the
description down below the link is there
for your convenience moving on outside
of twin motion now if we come across to
our actual browser whatever you're using
Safari Chrome it doesn't matter it's
literally on the internet you're gonna
have a variety of different places you
can find some awesome stuff to add into
your project of course you're gonna be
able to find things from Globe plants
which is the series sponsor for this
twin motion tutorial and full course so
please do check them out there is a link
in the description down below and if you
wanted to download any extremely high
quality plans you could find it right
here on Globe plants for example this
fiddle leaf tree right here is
absolutely stunning the details are
Exquisite and to be honest it's
basically in every Australian's house so
it is almost a staple for anybody in
Australia creating 30 renders we can
dive into 3D Sky 3D sky to the best of
my knowledge it used to be a Russian
website that's kind of been converted
into 3dsguy.org
but it is an incredible resource with
some amazing high quality 3D models
the downside is not everything is free
and you can only get three free
downloads per 24 hours so if I wanted to
site search for dining table first of
all I could spell it right with one n
and you see there's some incredible
stuff things that you see in those high
quality renders that people are charging
hundreds of thousands of dollars for and
if you download one of these once off
you can have it forever I like to Simply
hit the little free tab scroll down and
select fbx because twin motion works the
best with fbx files and then try and
find a table that I like you can
literally pick anything that you like
and download it relatively quickly and
free of charge I don't love any of these
tables so I'm not even going to try it
find something that's amazing let's
simply scroll up pick this table here
and you're gonna have to sign in or
create an account so I'm going to sign
in and then I'm going to hit the free
download button for me it's downloaded
as a raw file so all I need to do double
click it'll open up
what you'll notice in this unarchiving
screen here that I've dragged across the
file name is like I mentioned before
you've got some Russian letters because
it's probably a Russian website but it
also straight up aligned to us it said
there'd be an fbx file and it's only
providing us a 3ds Max and an obj file
we can still use the obj file so we can
definitely export that out but
unfortunately we didn't get our xbf file
so now that we've exported all of these
items we can come back into twin motion
we can dive down into our import file
press the plus button come across to
geometry and go open find the table in
your downloads file and you'll see only
the obj file is active so let's click on
that let's open it up and import on the
right hand side on the scene finder if
you scroll across the bottom select
table and pan around until we see the
main cursor you can hover over this
yellow sphere in the middle drag and
drop it roughly in front of you tab
across and scale the object accordingly
the problem with obj's in Twin motion is
first of all they import the wrong way
they Port the wrong size so you have to
do quite a lot of work to make them
actually appear as they need to
personally what I do is I delete that
table I would go back to 3D Sky use
another one of my free downloads let's
try this one download it go through that
same process
find the fbx file this time open that up
and import it into our project now that
table will reappear it'll be a much
better size it is the correct scale the
correct format rotate it around once
again unfortunately those textures
didn't come across exactly as we need
them to be it's mainly the timber that
didn't come into play so we'll select
those wood legs go texture go open
import the wood and there we go now we
have our wooden table exactly as
pictured but not perfect so
unfortunately when you're playing with
free 3D models you don't get the best of
it the best you kind of have to work
around it make it work but otherwise
when you're playing with the paid
objects it is so much easier if you
wanted to go through work your way
through all of these rooms obviously
there's a couple bedrooms in here
another bedroom a master suite with some
Cabinetry potentially an additional
gymnasium in the rear your bathroom all
sorts of stuff happening in this model
you can go ahead add it all in so as one
final example if we were to go to
sketchbab we were to go back into our
furniture we can drag and drop this high
quality bed into our project so that it
appears cantilevering off this
absolutely stunning bedroom at the edge
and we can continue working our way and
mastering twin Motion in the next
episode